ti stai bene attento 3 2 1
[Musica]
facile no voglio vedere ma io voglio
mettere tutta tanto più mangiatutto
tutta presso morto è chiaro mamma mia
che paura
[Risate]
ei ma taranto un attimo non ho capito il
gioco che cosa stiamo guardando a qui
esattamente
questo è proprio un vampiro
principianti di aspirare di tutto
qualcosa deve essere andato storto
sì sembra non capire la nostra missione
come cosa stiamo facendo stiamo
pianificando
la conquista del mondo
dobbiamo trasformare tutta l'umanità
bambini noi dobbiamo
conquistare il mondo
giovane discepolo
noi siamo qui adesso inizieremo nelle
città vicine a mietere i nostri primi
alleati
ci trasformeremo i piccoli bambini
proprio come te sì sì sperando di una
trasformazione funzioni perfezione ero
anche un po meglio rispetto a tutti i
materiali
c'è qualcosa di strano e mio padrone
dracula mi dispiace ho effettuato io
questa trasformazione ma non so che cosa
sia andato storto ma può essere che il
problema non sia la trasformazione ma il
problema sia soltanto lui non mi è mai
capitato in miliardi di anni ma potrebbe
anche essere in effetti non era molto
normale neanche prima
hai ragione fate non ho capito chi è di
là della normale
ma lascia stare continuiamo con il piano
della mobilità conquista biffi dubbio ma
nido si contento che tra poco morderà i
anche tu il tuo primo umana lo
trasformerà in un vampiro
si è visto non lo so io pochettino più
legato al cibo al cibo con un normale
diciamo tipo la pasta pasta aglio
peperoncino o no
onofrio lo posso mangiare la pasta e il
francese non
formale io voglio continuare la festa a
file così un francini voglio vedere
meglio voglio mettere tutta tutto quanto
tutto tutto adesso morso a un chiaro
mamma mia che paura tutto tutto
bruce ketta calaiò le bruschette
l'angelo che posso dirvi chiare io non
lo sopporto più ce ne sbarazziamo mi fa
avere davvero un po vi prego in cosa
potremmo trasformarlo
in un candelabro
no ma che cosa state dicendo io non
voglio essere un candelabro terreno con
l'albero con labbro ed io trovo
accostare il mondo adesso al vii vi dico
il mio piano siete d'accordo è tanto
chiaro allora secondo me iniziato questa
parte tutta questa bella palude verde
perché secondo me qui c'è più attivo
partendo da qui possiamo espanderci non
può andare più verso nord più per
fermare i laghi le montagne poiché ne so
magari non molto in montagna possiamo
prendere un po di sole li scendere giù
al mare e prendere un altro pò di sole
anche lì al mare per cercare di
conquistare
e tutta la vera vita del mondo che
pensate vi piace come piano è ora
ovviamente ci possiamo fermare per
mangiare in tutti i posti che visitiamo
tipo assaggiare tutti i piatti locali
man mano che ci spostiamo che ne pensate
siete d'accordo
l'unica cosa che dovrai mangiare sangue
umano
60 io preferirei mostra un bel panino
per fare un bel piatto di spaghetti che
giri di origini e poi pubblicato anche
resa una pasta un po che tira più
più terza rispetto al fango in mano se
vuoi lo elimino subito no con ida
migliori potremo usarlo come esca
per adescare degli altri umani sì certo
aspetta come hai capito bene come esca
escan e senza prego esca dalla porta
continuiamo il nostro piano di
espanderci e conquistare il mondo e voi
vorreste essere dei vampiri con minore
avete lasciato un mi piace qui sotto
dobbiamo sempre muoverci di notte di
notte che stai dicendo io di notte dormo
abbiamo fatto un paio di ore già di nota
alle dieci e mezzo dialetto come si fa a
di notte si dorme di giorno si mangia lo
sanno tutti
di giorno ma che dici tu perdendo la
pazienza non permetterò farlo arrabbiare
vero hai ragione tra cola non ce la
faccia più neanche i radi torna più
vanta di notte più barmen
basta non ne posso più
allieva mia prediletti fai un training
ma questo un giovane vampiro non troppo
vampiro fai un training veloce da
vampiro si mio padrone provvedo subito
iniziamo con le basi
il morso il volo è giusto iniziamo con
il morso da vampiro dai su sbrigati
slegati principiante mesi di là si
tratta di parole qualcosa allora lezione
numero uno di errore un vampiro di
diventare un vero vampiro devi imparare
a mordere
carini io sono proprio border morta del
panino mandateli mordere il collo per
far diventare le altre persone vampiri
ad esempio se questo è il collo di una
persona devi fare così
ok posso provarci anch'io a spring sa
cosa posso dare ecco ecco ecco cosa da
una zucca
cosa sta facendo
ma che stai facendo questo non sembra il
collo di una persona effettivamente un
pochino croccante pronto non riuscito a
far segno qui non lo fosse non riuscirà
a trasformare in un bottino non riuscirò
mai a diventare un vero vampiro
prima prova
ok seconda prova fondamentale
dell'essere banchina trasformarsi in
pipistrelli e il volare pronti se stai
bene attento ok 3 2 1
facile no basta fare 3 2 1
che faceva favolando dopo l'anno no
mibac e non sto volando ci riprovo a
saper ci riproverò
ora è
[Musica]
scappato qualcosa mi fa
bene un ormai una rete tutte le prove
aiuto noi
ci siamo
troppo umiliante
mari bambino mi ha chiamato possibili
che cosa vuole perché ci sta guardando
così strani dimmi dimmi fitti fitti
il bambino vuole rovinare i nostri piani
il popolo è stato buono è stato bravo
allora dicevamo come conquistare
quest'area del
ma cosa sta facendo il cane
al baule che contiene il libro è frutto
no
no ho preso il libro no ma le cose
stanno peggiorando
wow è scomposto il conte dracula
che cosa è successo
il libro vitale
sono tornati normali e di
soggiogarli non riesco un pallone bene
adesso il libro il libro è stato berlino
qui libro per quel libro termine salvato
servino preso il libro dal baule ha
catturato trappola aspetta ma cos'è
tutto questo buio a cedere un po di
luciano non siamo più un bambino
guarda l'ex ex
c'è riuscito a catturare anche
lo sapevo che potevo contare su di voi
lo sapevo grazie anche al tuo aiuto l'ex
sei stato bravissimo da cinzia quelle
informazioni che grazie a berlino
quindi abbiamo finito tutta la challenge
abbiamo catturato tutte le creature di
storie paurose
no non è un ex non mi dispiace dirvelo
ragazzi però ancora ancora non è finita
come no l'ex ma chi è rimasto ancora mi
dispiace dovervi dire questo ma mancano
ancora ben due
creature questo sono queste due creature
ragazzi per scoprire le altre due
creature dovete leggere il libro di
storie paurose le trovate qui se non ce
l'avete ancora andate a prenderlo e
arrivata l'ora di andare ragazzi questo
lo lascio a voi è in buone mani ci
vediamo io degli impegni ricordatevi che
ci avete bisogno di me basta chiamarmi
ciao ciao e ragazzi come ha detto l'ex
trovate storie paurose a scuola di
misteri in tutte le librerie online
non potete non averlo coprirete un sacco
di cose qua dentro devi sapere nei
commenti se lo vede e ora ci vediamo
alla prossima avventura ciao ciao io
corre subito a leggerlo tutto